beging there is absolutely no separation
between you and Karissa at this moment
head-to-head you guys are having the
identical line scor you drew the first
game you drew the fourth game against
each other and won every single game
after that what do you need to create
that
separation I don't know I think we need
four more rounds for that right
absolutely or tie breaks who knows we're
going to have to wait and see tell us
about today's game this was not an easy
one you were playing a two-time national
champion how did you approach it and
when did you feel like you're starting
to slowly take
over mhm uh I feel like after the
opening I was already better because she
started to thing and she started to mix
up the ideas I feel like she uh Queen C7
is one idea Bishop G Bishop G6 and
Knight F5 is another one so she was very
undecisive so I felt like I should be
already better I felt like I'm putting
pressure and after the game we talked uh
a bit and then she said she didn't
expect E4 at all uh which was like a
nice opening choice I got lucky I guess
absolutely and it felt like you knew the
plans you knew what you had to do in the
position as you mentioned she was mixing
up a few too many ideas and it was at
this point when you started finding this
plan opening up the C file and then this
very aggressive move G4 followed by h
four tell us your uh train of thought
that led to you making this
decision well uh the thing is that I
grew up playing E4 I'm an E4 player I
played bunch of uh carakan lines
especially E5 is my main line here so it
was good to be back because I just
pretty much I know everything every idea
in the position so I wasn't afraid of G4
uh because I know this idea exists and
it's just um usually it's better to put
Knight on G7 for me uh first of all and
secondly if you look at the position
Knight is the only good uh piece they
they have so yeah on F5 so I felt like
if I play G4 H4 my position should be
already better but I didn't know how
better it is because I wasn't sure if I
should include a include A6 or not but
usually you should include A6 to make a
little bit like a weakness on C6 so I
felt like I was doing fine here and
perhaps that was uh one of her mistakes
as well not
playing A6 herself and blocking the
position as is allowing you to create
another weakness on C6 and then you guys
got into this end game after a few
trades and you got the pawn on G5 but
still things were not that easy because
the position remains a little bit close
at the same time you have the C file you
have that B3 in the bag in terms of
percentages how sure did you think that
you're going to win this game I was
absolutely sure I when I played King G2
I I saw I'm check mating and Knight C5
is coming she basically doesn't have any
moves she told me uh for her better idea
was Rook F7 she mixed up the rooms like
she played instead of Rook
f8 Rook F7 uh yeah Rook F7 here her idea
is like Knight G5 Rook F4 if I play F3
she wants to play Knight C Knight E3 and
then Rook f8 maybe mhm mhm because if I
play Rook E1 she can play uh Knight G G4
which seem yeah which seemed like a good
idea but even here I don't know like it
feels like her Knights on G7 is a
problem to be honest yeah especially
with the pawn on G4 right so you
definitely don't want to give that pawn
and you didn't you executed all your
tasks in this position you broke through
got the pawn on A7 and F finalized game
Bean congratulations uh big victory for
you a lot of games left still four
finals for you uh to create that
separation with Karissa will'll wish you
all success and we'll see you tomorrow
one quick
question yeah one quick question for you
um uh beam uh in this position that I
have on my board I don't know if you can
see it uh for for for for me uh I'm a
French defense player I'm a caroon
player and we always as French defense
players we love the square fi for our
night so I thought you played a really
really nice game and in fact you had too
easy a time in this game that you won uh
a very smooth Victory I thought the move
H6 H5 was blacks nais only abely I
thought yes absolutely I thought that's
the move uh that's the move that's why
at some point I thought maybe H5 was
better for me because uh if I take if
she Tes it's like her position is
collapsing basically and no no no that's
why I thought H5 is the move instead of
like taking on G5 I see and I was
thinking
uh but I here I thought I can take on G5
and I was calculating Knight H4 Knight
H4 okay so then at least in the so she's
fighting back if you take I take on G6
and queen G4 for right I P yeah no I
apologize I did it the wrong way uh
sorry beum yeah I would of course take
on G5 then take on uh G6 and F4 right I
wasn't sure yet but I felt like her best
idea is to play H5 right and then I'm
playing Queen uh Queen C2 F5 I feel like
my position should be better exactly I
did too I just thought that H5 was her
best chance of resisting and well
whatever you're doing
keep it up you're doing it very very
well very impressive yeah plus five uh
good luck uh for the remaining
rounds and yes thank you bigum and